the haze second derivative you know what
the derivative is right so there's this
process of differentiation so you have a
function you have a function right and
the process of differentiation that's
what gives us a derivative right and if
I'm calling the function f then I would
normally call the derivative F that
would be my ordinary notation for that
right so function you differentiate once
and it gives you a riveted but this
process here of differentiating you can
do it as many times as you like to
anything you'd like so if I were to do
it again right to differentiate a second
time then what you get is well another
derivative but this time what you're
getting over here is the derivative of
the derivative yeah that's a bit awkward
to say derivative of the derivative so
rather than calling it that being that
you got this through video first and
then you get this one second right we
call this guy the first to repeat okay
so from now on I'll rather than just
saying the derivative I'm gonna
generally say the first derivative and
then this one what you get after is
called the second one the second
derivative now carrying on this notation
here right
the - indicates excuse me the -
indicates I differentiated once okay so
therefore if I differentiate again I'll
just just laugh another - one there
right now you can see even though in
practice more or less will never have to
differentiate more than twice okay in
practice you can see though that this
kind of notation it's starting to UM
it's time to struggle in terms of its
flexibility good morning and versatility
because like do I have to add however
many dashes that I want and sometimes we
want to talk about just whichever
derivative you want
second third fourth fifth and the
derivative right so in this context
rather than just simply adding dashes
sometimes you will see instead of that
right way of writing in it you'll see
the earth and in brackets they'll put a
number up there like two four second and
that indicates all right I've
differentiated twice if you've got three
in brackets up there you'd appreciate it
three times knock up again okay so
function first review second derivative
okay now I'm just gonna leave it as an
open question that we know the first
derivative what it tells us about the
function is it tells us about grade in
fact that's how we defined the
derivative right the derivative is all
about that first principles it's just a
rise over run so therefore we also call
this the gradient function the first
derivative tells you about the gradient
of this function now just for now
because I want you to actually think
about it I want you to therefore show
you my well if this tells me about the
gradient of this what does this tell me
about like this is the geometric or
applications of calculus that's where
we're heading I don't want to spoil it
yet because actually the fruit of I'm
like how learning happens is by your
brain working on something attorney
around your head I'll give you an answer
eventually but if I give you the answer
right now you actually get less
opportunity to think about so I want you
to think about and I'm deliberately
gonna leave this blank and we will come
to what if these would to find it it's
very shortly okay but you just have to
think about it now before we just start
computing some really simply this is the
notation which you will see probably
most frequently so it's not my favorite
it's not my favorite it's not very
descriptive and also as I've mentioned
before that - often just Yankee you
don't see it there or you do just a
mistake it for something else so here's
the way that I prefer to write it and
you'll see this notation just as often
okay functions we often say well I'm
gonna call my function why rather than
yeah right like y equals x plus 5 X plus
6 in fact we've seen this a lot before
we met
function notation we know that since
we're taking the gradient right where I
think that rise over run so again if I
differentiate I get dy over DX and I
read that I read that as rise over run
okay rise over run now
that's the change in Y which is rise and
that's the change in X but you can see I
can use this notation to show this
process of differentiating really was
take the Y and slap this down on the
front right you remember we talked about
this just been a while so that's why I'm
so treating isn't you we call this guy
the differential operator it means take
whatever that is right and see how it's
changing with regard to X and you can do
that for anything you can do it for
anything for instance here's a function
right this is the function for the area
of a circle I'm calling I'm naming my
function aid right well I can think
about how does a change as the radius
changes that's all that means
right how are they changing in
comparison to each other how's Y
changing in comparison to X equal a
gradient okay so being actively being
that this differential operator is what
we slap in front of something every time
we differentiate when I go for the first
review on the X to the next one this guy
is the derivative of this guy right so
it's D on DX of deep wine on DX did you
see that like that's all I've done I
said that means differentiate what have
you got in front so really they actually
should be they should be something in
there but the something has changed this
time what I differentiated was Y so if
you wanted the X but now I'm
differentiating something else now just
like saying the derivative of the
derivative which by the way is exactly
what this notation indicates just like
that's a bit of a mouthful this is also
a bit of nothing so mathematicians have
said well hold on a second I've got DX
on DX right sorry an on DX and another
on the air so I've got two of them there
right
I could just say I have two of them
multiplied together like they actually
can be dealt with kind of as fractions
and we saw that we have how to look at
limits right so this deal gift is not
just some random operator it's not just
a fraction because I wanted it to be a
fraction it's because gradient gives you
a fraction it's a ratio okay so that's
what I have in the bottom there are two
DX's so it's square up on the top I have
two or something else but it's not d
wise why doesn't appear twice does it
why only piece once what does it pay
twice it's the days that it's the
differential part of it right so we say
well there's two of those and there's Y
right so this is another piece of
notation you will see that indicates the
second root and I kind of prefer this
one in the same way that I prefer this
to this is kind of more descriptive